hey guys mkbhd here and welcome to
another high definition video and today
we're going to be taking a look at
google's latest creation if you couldn't
already tell google is yes one of my
favorite companies and today we're going
to be taking a look at this magnificent
browser here what you're looking at is
google chrome 7. you may have noticed it
looks just a little tiny bit different
from other versions of google chrome but
what are we going to be taking a look at
today
that includes benchmarking for some
speed tests some opening tests
and some other things like that and just
getting to know this browser a little
bit better first of all something i want
to address as we go ahead and view about
google chrome is that all your
extensions will still work so as soon as
you visit the link in the description
and of course check out the latest
version of chrome uh note that unlike
firefox and unlike opera and unlike
internet explorer all those hundreds of
thousands of extensions you have
available are gonna work so that's just
great
so the first thing i wanted to show you
uh was the new ability to use side tabs
say i have a number of tabs open here
say tumbler i have open you might have
noticed i actually do have a tumbler now
might be a little bit late what i want
to do over here is uh right click on the
tabs and what we can do is hit that use
side tabs button and you can see it
immediately switches to this interesting
little view
that i kind of kind of like kind of
don't like but you know it's it's new
and it's something most other browsers
haven't had the ability to i believe
opera does and this
ability allows you to just add new tabs
simply just like this and x the amount
on the left-hand side here it does save
some vertical screen space if you have a
wide screen monitor this can be very
helpful as you don't have a whole lot of
room from top to bottom so this is
really cool and of course in order to
switch back you right click and uncheck
use side tabs and bam you're right back
into this view of the top tab view so
that's the first thing about google
chrome 7.
thing i'm going to show you is over here
on this wrench this is something that
has been constantly evolving through
versions of chrome
and i'll go ahead and show you right
here so i type in test of course we have
google instant up here what we're going
to do is go to well first of all i'll
walk you through this whole thing here
you have the new tab button which is
ctrl t the new window and new incognito
window button there still is no ability
to use a new incognito window but our
new incognito tab you can also have this
copy button edit copy and paste right
here so if i hit copy
you can just go ahead and copy
what is highlighted
there
and
go ahead and paste it just like that
didn't exactly work that time but if i
had a text field open
it would definitely have worked
hopefully
well well
obviously these things are still in beta
but obviously obviously obviously
obviously obviously when you get this
working together it should work when the
full version of google chrome is out
obviously
i gotta stop saying that by the way you
have the full screen button you have the
zoom buttons and you have all your
typical buttons here now you know when
you go under tools you also have the
extensions button which was usually in
the main section of google chrome but
you have your extensions button over
here on the left hand side under tools
now and you also have the ability to
create an application shortcut which i'm
going to do now
when you click that i'll go ahead and
just put it on my desktop i don't want
it on my start menu or anything and
click create it just makes a little uh
little window here
and it's actually just a program
literally an application you don't have
a url bar or anything fancy like that
it's just a google
google.com
box and you can of course use instant
search in there and it could be a nifty
little application
also you have uh that on your desktop
which i'll go ahead and delete
so that's an interesting little feature
that's adopted from google chrome 6 that
they've carried along into version 7.
so now something i want to show you is
the fish tank test this is a performance
test uh it's pretty much the next best
thing to the asset three tests and this
tests hardware acceleration i have this
link here in the description it'll be
shortened with bitly but trust me uh
when you visit it it will be this link
i'm going to go ahead and paste it up
here in the top and we'll see if we can
get chrome to respond here
and we'll go ahead and visit the
microsoft this is usually used to test
internet explorer and basically what you
can go ahead and do is test a fish tank
this fish tank animation here
so typically it'll be running at a
slightly higher frame rate but right now
we have this little fish swimming around
the tank in internet explorer when they
introduced the new version this was a
big deal with hardware acceleration
and if we were using chrome 6 you would
be able to tell
this is
1280x720 i'm not sure oh it's smaller
here uh it would be a much slower
animation and if we got up to just 10
fish in chrome 6 you'd be down to about
12 frames per second here and if we got
up to 20 fish with a screen recorder
going it would be almost unplayable you
couldn't see movements it'll be in a
single digit frame per second it'll be
really slow and with hardware
acceleration well it's just playable at
a much higher frame rate
of course it's not a game but you can
definitely see this is much nicer
so the last thing i'm going to show you
guys is the acid 3 test and of course
google instant takes us there
immediately and google has been pretty
much mastering the asset three tests for
a while now google chrome pretty much
dominated it google chrome five google
chrome six they both killed it and
google chrome 7 is no exception you'll
get up to 100 out of 100 in the acid 3
test and i one more thing i want to
demonstrate to you guys is that yeah it
does open really quickly you can see
over on the side here i'm going to go
ahead and drag a copy to my desktop so
you can see how fast i actually open
google chrome and you can count down the
milliseconds from the time i click
access the internet
to the time i'm on the internet so it is
a very fast browser there's been nothing
to bring me back from firefox nothing to
bring me to opera nothing that this
browser can't do that any other browser
can do so if you've been on internet
explorer if you've been on firefox or
opera or something something just out
there maybe chameleon or some other web
browser i highly suggest you give
version 7 beta of google chrome a try as
it is pretty much the best software i
have ever used and something i use more
often than anything else on my computer
so this has been mkbhd with a sli sweet
little video about google chrome 7. i'm
getting back into the screencast if you
guys couldn't tell this one was a more
casual video but i hope to talk to you
guys in the next episode of mkbhd and
until then thank you for watching peace